hi i'm kevin o'leary from Dragon's Den
and shark tank I'm wearing a crisp Tom
Ford from Harry Rosen oh yeah baby ernor
business is so disciplined in scientific
it's black and white either you make
money or you lose it music is chaos you
need both in your life there's no
question about it rock and roll versus
business come on it's perfect it's thing
in the yang that's the left side right
side together I'd love to stay here all
day it's funny I think a lot of people
have you wondering what are you doing at
avatar shop with kevin o'leary it might
be a little known fact that you are
actually quite than just a lot oh I love
guitars and I love great clothes and why
not put them together there we go here
we are I think in deal-making you need a
combination of many things and I've had
some catastrophic failures in my life
and business and some great successes
luckily the successes are more than the
failures and that's what anybody can say
about a scorecard and business to try
and get more wins and losses but I think
you need to be creative you have to be
personable you have to be a bit of an
artist and a scientist at the same time
you want everybody to win and yet you
know it's a competition and the
scorecard is money and I like that game
here's the here's my philosophy I don't
need more money I wish I had more time
so my number one commodity for today an
asset is the use of time I want to make
sure that every minute of every day is
well used and doing something I enjoy
that's it that's my role today and I
want to give back and I think that's a
good place to be I'm enjoying myself
kevin o'leary the persona I mean you're
a tough tough talk from kevin o'leary
and even in your memoir there's some
tough talk is there a softer side
there's a reason they call me mr.
wonderful and I'll tell you what it is
it's because I always tell the truth and
I think sometimes people mistake the
truth for being harsh if you always tell
the truth you never have to remember
what you said so that's what I do some
people don't like it I couldn't care
less tell me a little bit about the new
book I'm really excited about this book
what I've tried to do is take all of the
lessons that I've learned and you know I
think about all the people i work with
all the mistakes I've made all the
successes I've had and put it into one
book if there's a book you want to read
about life and money this is it what do
you think is the biggest issue facing
fitting busy these days government the
biggest problem we've got is over
regulation in our taxes are too high
what's the biggest business in Canada
Canada so the Prime Minister and his
team whoever that person a woman is has
the biggest and most important job in
this country to make sure that we stay
on track and sometimes they get lost and
of course we're all tied together in a
global economy so that could be bad
that's why every day you've got to pick
up the guitar and play it for now it's
absolutely crucial you understand what
your suit is linear business it's your
calling card I want a crisp suit I want
business attire I want people to walk
into our office to say wow these guys
know what they're doing how you dress
communicates that way it works it's the
key it's absolutely important and Harry
has always been about you know educating
man trying to manage their brand because
every man is a brand and clearly you've
got the brand figured out the guitars a
new accessory but it works no heaviest
right it's more than that though if
you're a well-dressed
you float into a room your notice
everybody understands the harmony of the
way you look if you're mismatched if
your shoes don't work if your ties off
if the knot isn't just right it's so
glaring that you become the focus of
attention for the wrong reasons you know
what's expensive looking bad in business
Kevin thank you so much thank you thank
you I'll play this wonderfully tired